how old are you here Bradley shave the
beard off a few years off me I don't
know I think I was my birthday I think
maybe three or something how does that
picture get out in the world how do we
know what my mom sends pictures out all
this and it's you're gonna feel the wind
okay how's your face okay um I just
heard you say that sly is mischievous
yes I'm not mischievous okay so you get
straight to the point I'm a killer okay
this doesn't work I bite your knees
don't anticipate okay I'm kind of come
close all right let me just measure
let me just man
[Applause]
no I went up to when she was shooting I
was shooting something in Montreal so I
flew back to see the kids and and my
wife and I remember customs everything
was fine and and then one week just got
unlucky and there was a guy about my age
seemed a bit grumpy and he said you see
he said yeah I said you're an actor and
I said yeah he goes what do I know you
from I said I don't know if you'd know I
mean we did the American version of your
British office strike one I love that
show I get it I get it
and then he said who you visiting my
wife and he says she an actress and I
said yeah said what I know her I said I
don't know and he said what's her name
and I said Emily Blunt as he was writing
something anyway you talking of
sleepwalking Jamie Dornan hello now you
don't sleep eat sleep eat you don't see
Pete probably not no no but you do
sleepwalk listen I I that I'm aware of
I've slept once in my life I was about
11 or 12 I've told some shockers on this
show before I woke up and my dad was at
the end of my bed and he said morning to
me morning you said your man willing to
tell me not really slept slept well you
said do you think you slept last night
not usually do that sort of thing is
them well someone's done a poo in the
bath
you're famous for your celebrations when
you win you like winning you like to
celebrate winning so now you're in the
world of soccer have you come up with
your your goal celebratory dance / move
not really I'm thinking I like the slide
you know I mean when the foot was
running me slide only looks good so
imagine if I run slide then I hit the
pose have you any moves you could
suggest I don't think he wants to do one
of my movie
I only know like basically one
[Applause]
big reaction sort of confuse reaction
from fans here's some of the tweets when
it got announced I mean Dumbledore just
got 200% Jude Law is playing a young
heart and gay Dumbledore next we're a
CBC I'm sweating already this I think
sums it up quite nicely
Dumbledore more like Dumbleton so here
you are in a thought about a man
withdrawals and of course you to your
work have become dolls
there you are from the office oh yeah
what else we got we've got you from
anchorman I think you better without the
glasses
there you are Formica but that is a
really good dog kill the guy with a try
and then I keep in my own pocket
[Applause]
we must have seen this thing that goes
well every year this does them all for
God what's so weird is you only have one
Christmas album you notice I don't find
that as funny as everybody else six
members but there's supposed to be seven
what happened
there's a demon called remember well Jim
Jim in yes the guys seized up before the
rehearsal so I know but you can't be
Jimin today so
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna get a scholarship to Kings
College
I probably shouldn't brag but Aragon
amazing astonished the problem is I got
a lotta brains but no polish I got a
holla just to be heard with every word I
dropped knowledge I'm a diamond in the
rough
ash on a piece of coal trying to reach
my goal my power of speech unimpeachable
only 19 but my mind is older these New
York City streets get cold a shoulder
every burden every disadvantage I've
learned to manage I don't have a gun to
brandish I walk these streets famished
the plan is to fan this spark into a
flame but damn is getting dark so let me
spell out the name I am there yo e^x
again D er we are meant to be a colony
that runs independently meanwhile
Britain keeps on us endlessly
they tax us relentlessly thinking jaws
shows around Rosa spending spree penny
ain't never gonna say his descendants
free so there will be a revolution in
the century and to me he says in
parentheses don't be shocked when your
history book mentions me I will lay down
my life if it sets us free eventually
you'll see my descendants II and I am
NOT throwing away my shot at something
like that
[Applause]
[Music]